successfully the numbers are quite
sobering you know we've have over
135,000 deaths in this in this in this
pandemic for the United States we have
over three million cases if you look
globally this close to 600,000 deaths
and about 13 or 14 million infections so
this is a pandemic of historic
proportions I think we we can't deny
that fact it's something that I think
when history looks back on it will be
comparable to what we saw in in 1918 the
situation that is the current challenge
that we're facing right now is the
resurgence of infections in the south
and south western part of the country
but particularly in areas like
California Florida Arizona and Texas
they're seeing record numbers of cases
mostly interestingly among young
individuals strongly suggesting the link
between attempting to open and in many
respects as we saw pictures of and and
the photos and films of is that and that
we'll get back to this in a moment about
responsibility where individuals mostly
young people were seen at bars
congregated in crowded places many of
them without masks which really adds
fuel to the fire so our challenge today
and tomorrow and next week is to try and
contain these outbreaks and get us back
on the track of being able to not only
contain but also to open to open safely
so bottom line it's a global serious
situation it's a serious situation in
the United States the United States
being a very large country and very
heterogeneous both geographically
demographically in other ways it's the
mixed bag some areas of the country are
doing really quite well and others are
being challenged as the states that I
just mentioned you said to compare it
and I'll do it briefly right now if you
look at the magnitude of the 1918
pandemic we're anywhere from 50 to 70
200 million people globally died I mean
that was the you know the mother of all
pandemics and truly historic I hope we
don't even approach that with this but
it does have the makings of the
possibility of being you know
approaching that in seriousness though I
hope that the kinds of interventions
that were going to be and are
implementing would not allow that to
happen but it does have strong
similarities with that in that it was
the emergence of a brand new infection
that was influenza this is coronavirus
that you know essentially thrust itself
on the human population and had two
characteristics that are the thing that
make it as I say the perfect storm and
that is a virus that jumps species but
that almost immediately has an
extraordinarily capable and efficient
way of spreading from human to human
simultaneously with having a
considerable degree of morbidity and
mortality and that's what we're facing
now and you asked me to compare it with
other outbreaks and I think I can you
examples of each of those and I'll do it
very quickly that had one or the other
of those characteristics but not both
and that's what I refer to when I say
the perfect storm so let's take the
threat of the bird flu that you and I
had a lot of experience when you were in
the department and that is the h5n1 and
the h7 at 9:00 it jumped from a chicken
to a human
it had pre-pandemic potential but what
it didn't do it didn't spread from human
to human so if you were unlucky enough
to get infected you had a 35 37 40
percent mortality but it was a dead end
mostly with humans it didn't go from
human to human then you had the
situation with the night 2009 h1n1 which
was very efficiently transmitted from
human to human
but pathogenic ly it was a weak virus I
mean the deaths that year were less than
with a seasonal flu so you had the two
ends of the spectrum one transmitted
well didn't kill one kill but didn't
transmit well and what we have now is a
virus
that is very capable of spreading for
human to human and even though it has a
wide range of impact from 20 to 40
percent other people who have no
symptoms so individuals to get
moderately sick very sick serious enough
to go to the hospital
serious enough for intensive care
ventilation and even death so it's a
very unusual virus in that the range of
severity is so great and wide which
actually leads to confusion on the part
of people as to whether this is really
serious as some people say it is well
it's not serious for some people but
it's deadly serious for others so I'll
stop there and that's kind of the
overview no that's exactly that's
incredibly helpful Tony and really my
follow-up is because I think the virus
has this disparate impact as you've
described there's some issues than the
public debate now that we really helpful
if you could help clear on I mean one
would be there is this discussion about
whether a rise in total US cases as a
result of testing alone as opposed to
the disease progressing and to is should
we take comfort the death rates are
declining which they are even as
infection rates increase and then this
recent discussion about the ability of
the virus to spread through aerosol eyes
form versus the droplets and I just if
you could just those issues keep have
been coming up regularly if you can
maybe be able to help us understand what
the science shows us yeah okay so first
hang on I just I want to write down your
questions okay
so sorry I was distracted with that so
the first question is is this just an
increase because of testing versus an
increase in well there's no doubt that
it's both I mean obviously the more you
test the more you're gonna pick up so
increase in testing is gonna give you
increases but there is no doubt that
there are more infections and we know
that because the percentage of cases of
the ten the cases that are tested that
are positive is increasing therefore
unequivocally you're see
a truly more new cases in addition we're
seeing now more hospitalizations which
lag behind infections and was starting
and we'll see though not as much as we
seem very likely more deaths so clearly
there are more infections the second
question is I think you hit it just
really should we take comfort that death
rates are declining okay so we've got to
be careful because remember the big
spike in the death rates that we saw was
the terrible situation that they went
through in New York City metropolitan
area in situations in Chicago and New
Orleans and Detroit and that death rate
happily is going way way down what will
happen is that we will likely see some
more deaths as people get hospitalized
but I doubt John that it's gonna go up
to the extent that we've seen before
mostly for a couple of reasons one is
that if you look at the age range of the
individuals who are getting infected now
as opposed to early on a few months ago
it's about a decade to a decade and a
half younger so even if young people
would some do get sick enough to get
hospitalized it is highly unlikely that
the death rate among them are gonna be
at the level of the death rate of what
we saw in the real core of the explosion
that we saw in the northeastern part of
the country and then the last really
other questions been the debate is the
extent to which the virus is transmitted
through aerosol that is still debatable
John in fact two minutes before I came
in I just read a summary analysis of it
and there's almost certainly that there
is a degree of aerosol occurrence the
degree of transmission aerosol wise is
very unclear most people think it is not
the dominant modality of transmission
but the definitive proof has not been
put I don't think it's dominant I think
it actually
occurs and for those listening to know
the difference is that droplet type of
transmission rarely goes beyond six feet
so if you cough sneeze or even talk a
droplet would tend to drop to the ground
which is the reason for the six feet
limit that we talk about about staying
away when you have aerosol it's in a
droplet that's less than five
micrometers which means it has the
capability of floating around so you
would expect that it does have the
capability not only Templi of floating
around but getting behind the mask
around the mask or in the mask so that's
what they talk about with aerosol I mean
that's very helpful if I don't turn this
over to moe now for the next question
hey dr. factory thanks again for joining
us today let's turn to the response a
little bit now you know as we've already
talked about the disease has hit the
United States harder than many other
nations around the world and as you
talked about it's not entirely just
because of of testing and starting a big
picture first you know how much of that
do you think has to do some of the
nations that have dealt with this maybe
a little bit more effectively have had
more of a coordinated national response
whereas we have opted for more of a
state-based or local or regional
response here in the United States is
that part of the disparity can we even
have a coordinated national response
yeah yeah States you know Moe it's it's
always easy to look back and say if we
had done this would it have been
different I mean that's always way you
know and that will happen when this is
over and people I'm sure analyzed it
every which way some of the things that
I believe have an impact on the
differences and I don't think we can
fully explain it is that in Europe for
example and in some of the Asian
countries when they shut down
essentially locked down they locked down
to the tune of about 90 90 plus percent
they really locked down we have a very
large in a very heterogeneous country
with different risks in different places
geographically and them again
and in reality even though we locked
down considerably
we only locked down the estimate is
somewhere around fifty fifty five
percent or so so when we had the
outbreak and in Europe they went up they
peaked and then they came right down to
baseline they really did go down from
thousands of infections to handfuls or
so of infections whereas in the United
States if you look at our curve for
better or worse we went up we peaked we
came down and we never really came all
the way down to baseline we stayed
around 20,000 a day of new cases until
the most recent surge when we went to 30
and 40 and 50 and then 60 so the issue
is we never got down to the baseline so
that when you started to open up
you had relatively few amounts of
infections to deal with whereas when we
opened up now you're seeing the surge
the reason for that a complicated mo and
there there are many the issue of how
one does a response you know we live in
a country that from its founding had a
Federalist bent to it where there were
states that had the independent right
and and capability of doing things their
own way in many respects that works to
our advantage in other situations
possibly that really was a little bit of
a disadvantage here very difficult to
make a definitive comment about the
contribution that that paid for the
difference between what we see here and
what we see in Europe let me toss it
over to John we all have so many more
questions right after John and mine as
quickly as possible before we go to the
students and this is just a reminder to
the students you can still continue to
submit your questions using the Q&A tab
at the bottom of your skin screen right
Tony speaking of the schools and
students you know many schools around
the country are announcing their
guidance week for the fall we had a
Georgetown but which is yesterday the LA
County and the
San Diego County Public Schools
announced that they would be online for
the entire fall the president many
others have been talking about of
reopening schools full reopening as
quickly as possible
the cdc's issued guidance describing
steps that schools can take to open
safely I guess what I'd love for you to
do is step back and just help us think
about how should how should schools
approach the upcoming academic year and
if you could clarify what we know now
about the risks of children teenagers
and young adults across that whole aid
cycle from K through 12 through higher
ed and and the risk that they present
among themselves but also with teachers
staffs and their families is what's the
right way to think about this as schools
go forward
okay so let's done for clarity let's
just talk about you know elementary
middle high school and not university
because there are major differences
there and we could get into universities
later but I think people are much more
focused on school so I start off with a
general principle and then work your way
towards the operational aspects and the
exceptions so as the general principle
we should try as best as possible to
keep the children in school for the
reasons that the unintended downstream
ripple effect consequences of keeping
the kids out of school and the impact on
working families and on other aspects of
society can be profound not to mention
the negative effect on the children so
as a principal we should try as the
default to get the kids to stay in
school
however that's gonna vary from where you
are in the country and what the dynamics
of the outbreak are in your particular
region so that's the reason why
although the fundamental principle is
there the one or the guiding principle
that is overriding is the safety and the
welfare
the children and the safety and the
welfare of the teachers so you've got to
take that into consideration so if
you're in the part of a country where
the dynamics of the outbreak a really
minimal if at all then there's no
problem at all in getting back if you're
in a situation where you're in outbreak
mode then you leave it up to the local
individuals as you've said in certain
California schools certain Florida
schools of making a decision based on
the judgment of making sure that safety
of the children and safety of the
teachers a paramount so you're guiding
the principle let's try and get them
open to the extent that we can but let's
take a look at the dynamics of the
infection in the area that you're in
thanks Tommy thank you well this maybe
is a little bit more less about the
response from the government more about
the response from citizens okay yeah I'm
glad you're here and I'm glad you're
speaking out and I'm glad that you are
giving students a chance to talk with
you because a lot of people are confused
right now about the state of the
pandemic and what they should be doing
my wife and I every night you sit down
from here on what we're allowed to do
with our kids based on we're comparing
different news stories we've read or
different pieces of guidance that we
picked up and I think a lot of the
confusion can probably be attributed to
three main three main issues one the
evolving nature of the pandemic has
resulted in more information and new
information and involving time guidance
to a growing body of deliberate
misinformation and disinformation that's
being spread much of it online
and three the polarization and growing
politicization of the discussion of the
pandemic right I mean just even this
past weekend the White House pointing is
some of your previous comments in order
to question some of the guidance so my
question is this given all of that
misinformation disinformation evolving
guidance increased politics in the
conversation how do people synthesize
all this information in order to make
the right decisions how do they know who
to trust
well that's a good question and it's
it's difficult you know to give you a
definitive answer except that for the
most part I believe for the most part
you can trust respected medical
authorities you know I believe I'm one
of them so I think you can trust me but
I would stick with respected medical
authorities who have a track record of
telling the truth who have a track
record of giving information and policy
and recommendations based on scientific
evidence and good data so if I were to
give advice to you and your family and
your friends of your family I would say
that's the safest bet to do to listen to
the recommendations from that category
of people but it's entirely
understandable how the public can get
mixed messages and then get a bit
confused about what they should do I
mean let me ask one quick follow-up
before tossing it back to John you just
mentioned data and you know there was a
story that broke literally moments
before we convene here today about
bypassing that data collection will now
bypass the CDC and go straight to HHS
and I'm wondering if you have any
thoughts on that sort of late-breaking
news no I know one of them bad ideas
about come
on late-breaking news that you didn't
read that's a surefire way to shoot
yourself in the foot I think I'll pass
on that one
fair enough fair enough all right we're
gonna go to John and then after that
right to student questions which will be
probably better than any of John or my
question and I think my last question is
we start to queue up the students Tony
really is and I know we asked a lot of
questions but it really does so far get
to the complexity of this experience the
country is going through but you know
most of the people on this webinar are
students and there are young adults and
I guess we start to bring people on I'd
love to ask you to say well given what
we know now given everything we've
talked about what is your message to
young people young adults teenagers you
know as more states open up summer tech
pausing but really focus on so what are
the risks and the responsibilities of
young people as we think as we as we
approach the pandemic where we are right
now even working well thank you for that
question John I was hoping someone good
because I think it's key it's really key
to what is going on right now with the
resurgence is that we're seeing in some
of the southern states and and I say
this with some trepidation because I
don't want to seem preachy about it but
since right now if you look at what's
going on in the country that the
infections are among young people very
likely contributed at least in part to
what you're seeing on TV of young people
gathering at bars crowded places
congregating many without masks there is
an understandable situation where a
young person could say you know
statistically the chances of my getting
into trouble by getting infected are
much smaller than an elderly person and
a person with an underlying condition
and
I as a young person I'm really quite
healthy it doesn't matter to me I'd
rather be there sipping my margarita at
a bar in a crowd well
you
but the chances are you're going to
infect someone who then will infect
someone who then will be a vulnerable
person who can get sick who can get
hospitalized who could even die so not
only are you propagating the outbreak
but you're actually putting other people
in danger so I would hope you could
appeal to the young people to not only
take the individual personal
responsibility but think about your
societal responsibility and that's what
I mean when I say we're all in this
together everybody has a place and a
role in getting this outbreak under
control and you are not caring whether
you get infected or not is not a good
way to get the outbreak under control to
get it under control means you don't let
yourself get infected and you don't
spread to anybody else and again I I say
that with some trepidation because I'm
not blaming anyone and I think people do
this innocently they don't mean to be
part of the problem but inadvertently
they are a part of the problem and
that's the message we've got to get
across thank you Tony thank you very
much and so maybe I'll turn this back to
Moe because we're going to be able to
bring in some student questions here
next so yeah all right we've got a lot
of questions so dr. Farhat you were
going to try to get through them as many
of them as we can
our staff will notify students when we
are ready are getting close to being
ready to call on you when we do make
sure you are as we say in the business
broadcast ready is you're going to be up
on screen asking dr. pouchy your
question directly when we call on you
make sure you introduce yourself tell us
who you are where you're zooming in from
your school year field of study so that
dr. kouchi has a little bit of contest
and so with that our first question
comes from Varsha Minami Varsha tell us
introduce yourself I dr. G thank you for
coming to speak with us today
my name is Varsha and I am a senior in
the SF s school foreign service majoring
in international political economy and
I'm currently zooming in from Plano
Texas so I'm in a co bit hot spot at the
moment and I guess my question has to do
with like what young people can do to
contribute to D politicizing this
pandemic because I feel like a lot of
this pandemic has been kind of been like
controlled or like been impacted by
politics so I was just wondering what
young people can do to kind of make it
more about science and less about
politics well young I mean obviously
that that's a period it appears to be a
simple question but it's it's a
complicated situation that you're asking
about it's it's very tough for young
people to have an impact on
depolarization except by not being part
of the polarization in other words this
is a pandemic keep reminding yourself
and your peers that this is something in
which it doesn't matter who you are what
you are you're Republican Democrat any
of anybody else we're all in this
together
and the way you can do that is by
fortifying each other in what you can do
to essentially be part of what I just
said protect yourself the best thing you
could do is protect yourself and fortify
your colleagues in their attempts
hopefully successfully to protect
themselves from getting infected the way
to the way to squish-squash out an
outbreak is to have not anybody get
infected so you're not getting infected
Marcia is a big contribution to what we
need to do so hang in there do your
thing and don't get involved in any of
the political nonsense that's a waste of
time and a distraction
alright thanks for the question Marsha
next up we've got John fig excuse me if
I'm mispronouncing any of the names but
John introduced yourself to dr. country
hi dr. Khatri
I'm John Figge and I'm coming to you
from Bryn Mawr Pennsylvania I'm a
sophomore junior in the school foreign
service I'm a global business major and
my question what kind of studies can we
can we do right now in the middle of the
pandemic about masks and transmission of
the disease or are we just relying on
anecdotal evidence because we're not
able to do those kinds of studies right
now that's a good question
John right now if you look at the meta
analyses and there are pretty good
studies of meta analyses about the
efficacy of masks both for preventing
you from infecting someone else as well
as someone else infecting you I'm pretty
good I would not want to do a randomized
controlled study because that would be
having people not wear masks and see if
they do better right now I'm convinced
enough in the summation and the I would
say the totality of the data that has
been analyzed by meta-analysis that I'm
convinced that the benefit of wearing a
mask clearly is there and is better than
not wearing a mask and I think to do
this study would be kind of difficult to
do because then you'd have to tell
people not to wear masks and I'm not
about to tell them that alright jump
thanks for the question next up we've
got Caleb Caleb yeah Caleb go ahead and
introduce yourself hi
thank you dr. Falchi I am Caleb I am a
senior in the school foreign service
curly zooming in from Washington DC my
question is on the World Health
Organization so the Trump administration
has criticized the WTO whu-oh and has
also submitted plans to withdraw from
your organization how do you believe
da da ba Joe has done in terms of
coordinating a global response to a
pandemic and what our thoughts to the
plans for withdrawing well Kalyan
I mean obviously this is a complicated
situation
you
of the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases they are an
imperfect organization they have made
mistakes but I would like to see the
mistakes corrected and for them to be
much more in line with the kinds of
things that we need there are some very
good people at the whu-oh including the
director general who I know very well
and I have a lot of colleagues that I've
interacted with over the years so I hope
this kind of tension between the United
States and the w-h-o somehow or other
ultimately gets settled in a favorable
way because the world does need a whu-oh
for outbreaks like this and even for the
general health of the globe to
coordinate it so I hope this thing gets
resolved in a way that we find that's
although favourable Caleb thanks for the
question
next up we've got Andrea hobby Andrea go
ahead and introduce yourself
hello my name is Andrea Purim that's the
Maryland I'm a current graduate student
epidemiology at Georgetown University
and my question is um talked about you
what is the best way I guess babies for
policy whose solutions that defray the
cost of testing as schools reopen I know
a lot of schools they would like to do
testing for like all students and they
come back and it's just an enormous cost
addition to the current like financial
losses there well you know I I don't
really have a good answer for that
because that's them and when I start
talking about money and course I'm out
of my area you want to talk about other
things I'd be happy to do it you know a
lot of the testing can actually be free
of course
so I ending upon where you are and what
you're doing so there are many things
that have to do with testing and even
treatment of Kovac that really is
without of course since I'm not as
familiar with it Andrea's as I'd like to
be I would refrain from making comments
because as you know that often gets one
into trouble
and I occasionally like to avoid that
right thanks Andrea
okay next up we've got Claire Cushman
Claire go ahead hi thanks for taking my
question
I'm Claire I'm a rising junior in the
college studying psychology and
economics and I'm zooming in from the
Boston area so my question is can you
outline some of the reasons from your
perspective and expertise as to why the
koban 19 pandemic has disproportionately
affected poor communities and
communities of color and more
importantly explain what the federal
government should do to mitigate these
inequalities yeah especially in the
event of another global health crisis in
the future yeah well great question I'm
glad I'm glad you asked it because I was
hoping someone would ask it so if you
look at minorities communities that's
african-american latina X and some
specks Native American was an Alaskan
Americans there are two areas in which
they find themselves disadvantaged the
first though one like does not like to
generalize but as a general demographic
group minorities find themselves because
of their economic and employment
situations in a situation where it's
less easy for them to protect themselves
from getting infected they have less of
a chance of sitting in front of a
computer
teleworking as opposed to being outside
with jobs that require exposure so their
chances of getting infected are greater
than the general population
that's disadvantaged number one
disadvantage number two is when they do
get infected given the social
determinants of medicine that have been
around for so long they have a much
greater incidence and prevalence of
comorbidities which lead to a poorer
outcome diabetes hypertension obesity
cardiovascular disease those kinds of
things which
them in a higher risk category so it's
what do you call a double negative
whammy that they get what can we do now
and what can we do in the long run what
we can do now is concentrate resources
in the areas where they are
demographically over-represented so that
they could have easy access to testing
that access to health care so that if
and when they do get infected they can
get into proper care early enough to
maybe mitigate some of the negative
consequences that we can do now the
longer range is do we have a commitment
which I hope we do to eliminate health
disparities which is a decade-long
commitment you're not going to do that
overnight there are so many things that
you can do to modify the reasons why
they have more hypertension they have
more diabetes they have more obesity so
we can do stuff now and we can make a
commitment to do things in the long run
thanks Claire okay next up we've got
Dominic Gordon Dominic introduce
yourself hello my name is Dominic Gordon
and I'm a freshman at a school foreign
service I'm just gonna enter my freshman
year this year now I know it's some
boring things about foreign policy
because school foreign service but I
have a question about how how we can
have international relations affects our
ability to contain pandemics and how
greater cooperation amongst nations
could help us prevent a second pandemic
or a future incident that was that was
my question and thank you for your
service dr. Anthony Fauci because I you
don't know how amazing this is this week
to you well it's my pleasure it's it's
nice to speak to you Dominic so you
really bring up a very important point
the word pandemic almost answers your
question because pandemic means all so
it essentially is global so if you're
going to talk about identifying
responding to and containing pandemics
you've got to think globally you can't
think in a vacuum of your own country so
international relationships trust
between countries transparency
agreements to have things like global
health security network which we try to
have those are all critical to an
adequate response and we have so many
examples of when those things were not
optimal that our response was slowed and
we could have done better so you know I
mean in the issue I we had a couple of
students who are involved in studies of
foreign service I mean if there is
anything of a challenge that requires
international cooperation it's a
pandemic by the very definition of what
a pandemic is
alright Dominic thanks for the question
and welcome to Georgetown alright next
up we've got hunter condom hunter
my name is I'm a rising senior in the S
offense at Georgetown and I'm currently
in New Haven Connecticut my question is
it seems it was like we still don't know
whether having had the virus confers
immunity when will we find out that for
sure and will the answer that question
affect the vaccine and could it mean you
get more sick if you get the virus the
second time okay good good good
questions hunter so we will not have the
definitive answer to your question until
we're out many months and a year or more
to be able to definitively determine the
durability I think I could say with a
degree of confidence that if you get
infected and you recover it was because
your immune system and your immune
response suppressed and ultimately
eliminated the virus so if you were
infected I could say confidently that
you have immunity what I can't tell you
is how long that immunity is gonna last
I would hope that it lasts a substantial
period of time but we don't know because
we've only been involved in this
outbreak for five and a half to six
months does that impact the hexa nation
it does so what we're gonna do is hope
that when we do vaccinate individuals
that the vaccine would give protection
that's at least long enough for one full
seasonal cycle hopefully much more but
if it isn't there's always the
opportunity to give someone a booster so
that's the answer to your first two
questions the third question is that if
you get infected before and then get
infected again could it make it worse
you're talking about what they called
enhancement that's anybody induced
that's a phenomenon that we're studying
now I don't think I hope it won't be a
big deal there are
some infections were pre-existing
low-level inadequate immunity leads to
an enhancement of infection we've seen
that with respiratory syncytial virus
vaccine with dengue and we hope we don't
see it with Kovac but that's the reason
why when you do a vaccine trial you pay
a lot of attention to safety
so three good questions Thanks all right
thanks hunter next up April lung heart
introduce yourself hi dr. Bharti my name
is a pollen heart I'm a graduate student
at SSB thank you so much for being here
today and discussing all these things
with us my question for you was in a
very contentious type of political
climate how do you bridge that divide
between on the one hand the necessity to
disseminate critical information about
the seriousness of a disease and on the
other hand the need for that advice to
actually be accepted on both sides yeah
well the most important thing to do is
when you're dealing in what I think
you're referring to as a divisive
atmosphere in the country at whatever
level you call it is to stick to the
science and stick to the evidence and
avoid at all costs getting involved in
any of the political ideological
divisiveness if you want to get a
message across build up the confidence
in others that you are speaking the
truth and you are speaking and advising
on the basis of evidence and science
because that's the thing that's clean
and crystal clear there's not you know
ideology involved there's there's not
political persuasion involved just stick
with the data and use that to make
whatever advice or recommendation you're
going to do and you can get past all of
the other stuff that's unfortunately
background noise and often gets in the
way of what you're trying to do
okay thanks April next let's go to
Andrew Bialik Andrew go ahead and
introduce yourself afternoon dr. pouchy
thank you for being here my name is
Andrew biochem a rising junior in the
college studying government
I am from Long Island New York and my
question has to do with a lot of the
work that I do with the jerk on
disability Alliance and mental health
how do people around the world
specifically students and parents with
little children reconcile the mental
health component of going out and
leaving quarantine and isolation with
the risks that it might necessarily
bring along with it
yeah well that's really a great question
Andrew I'm glad you asked it that is one
of the reasons why it it's a complicated
situation you know we we need to contain
the outbreak and the kinds of
confinements and physical distancing
shutting down if you will have played an
important successful role in getting
cases down but the reason why it's
important to open the country again and
to try to get back to some degree of
normality it's not only because of the
inconvenience it's not only because of
the economic impact people losing their
jobs but what you're talking about it
what you're interested in it's also
important the strain on the morale and
the mental health of people being put in
a really abnormal situation like
lockdown is one of the things that you
need to consider and balance so you
don't want to open up and create a big
surge again that would cause you to take
a step backwards but on the other hand
you've always got to try in a good
prudent careful way to get back to some
form of normality one reason of which is
the point that you make it does have a
negative impact on everything from the
health of kids getting checkups to
mental health in general
so that's one of the things that we do
consider so thanks for that question
all right thanks Andrew all right next
up we've got Quentin Quentin go ahead
and introduce yourself hi dr. Fatih I'm
a rising senior in Georgetown College
I'm also working as a contact trace for
this summer and I was wondering what
steps should policymakers consider to
ensure that which country and which
groups within that country get a
deployable and effective vaccine first
but this does not magnify existing
social and geopolitical inequalities
well Quentin thank you for being a
contact tracer I I applaud you for that
we need you the idea about equities not
only in the distribution of vaccines and
scarce therapies but also in the
clinical trials that determine if they
work or not you want equitable
distribution because you want to make
sure that
you
community we have community engagement
and we have a number of mechanisms of
getting people together
you
people with underlying conditions
hopefully you could quickly get
everybody vaccinated or get the therapy
to everybody who needs it but sometimes
you have to make difficult decisions
that's the reason why you want to go by
the strongest medical and ethical
principles to guide you
Tony this China just a quick follow-up
could you just give us a couple of
sentences on the state of vaccine
development just your projection given
where we are right now when when we're
likely to have vaccines obviously
there's nothing guarantee but your sense
of the likely timeline well we're on a
good track John with some good news
that's either coming out today or
tomorrow the publication of the phase 1
trial for one of those candidates that
showed really good neutralizing
antibodies safe no adverse events but
good levels of neutralizing antibodies
on the vaccine that's gonna go into
Phase three at the end of this month at
the end of July then there are other
candidates that will soon be following
at the end of the summer the early fall
mid fall so I think we're in a pretty
good place when it comes to vaccines I
mean obviously you want to prove that
it's safe and less effective but if
things work out the way we hope they do
I think by the end of this year at the
beginning of calendar year 2021 we will
have enough information to know whether
the candidates that we're dealing with
are safe and effective and hopefully
apropos of Quentin's question we'll be
able to distribute it in a equitable
manner to a large number of people
so I'm cautiously quite optimistic about
that thank you Tony thanks and thanks to
Quentin for that for the question
all right next dan sacks go ahead I'm
Dan Stax I'm an incoming first year
college and I'll be studying linguistics
and so my answer to Maya the question I
had was answered a little bit but I
wanted to take it to about vaccines when
will it be released across the country
and across the globe and when we when
should we expect to have a complete
immunity and get over cope with 19 okay
good good group of questions then so you
know when you talk about when we will be
able to give it to everybody that's
assuming that my timetable is correct
and if it is I think as we get into the
Year of 2021
the companies who are involved in making
the vaccines promised that we'll have
many doses to the tune of a couple of
hundred million if that's one company
with a couple hundred million another
company feels that within a year they
could have a few hundred million up to a
billion so right away I'm feeling much
better about getting vaccine that's
distributed not only within our own
country but that they'll be able to have
doses from people throughout the world
who cannot afford nor are they in a
situation where it's very easy for them
to get vaccinated you should know that
no vaccine is going to be a hundred
percent protective what we hope is that
with a combination of people having
already been exposed and a vaccine
that's anywhere from seventy
seventy-five percent effective that
there will be enough herd immunity that
there will be a time Dan when you and I
don't have to worry about getting
infected with this awful virus that
we're having to deal with and I hope
that that time will be reasonably soon
and when I say soon I say within the
next year to a year and a half okay
thanks Dan we are getting close to the
end of our time I want to try to squeeze
in a couple more student questions if
possible so next up we've got Lauren
Lauren go ahead and introduce yourself
hi my name is Lauren I'm a second year
student at Georgetown Law School and my
question is do you believe that a
comprehensive contact tracing program
can be implemented on a national scale
in a way that would evade widespread
accusations about privacy violations yes
I do
firmly I mean I believe if done properly
if done correctly with people who are
the contact tracers that are trustworthy
and competent I think that this can be
done contact tracing is a very it's not
the only part of epidemic and pandemic
control but it really is a very
important part it becomes much more
important when you're in a containment
mode as opposed to a mitigation mode
because when you have such a wide
outbreak at the community level and you
don't really know because you have so
many asymptomatic carriers contact
tracing can be very problematic but in
the conditions where you have a low
enough rate of infection I think it can
be done Lauren of the conditions where
you're not going to worry about privacy
issues
you
okay thanks so much Lauren we are
running out of time so doctor I want to
ask one last question and that is
actually about our frontline workers
they you know they're out there on the
frontlines not only in health care
settings but in you know grocery stores
and transit and other essential
industries are we doing enough to
protect them what steps should we take
to protect them and their families
especially as this pandemic continues to
unfold well you know I think one of the
things was a question that one of the
students asked about prioritization of
essential workers with vaccines and with
therapies but I think what you would do
mo to protect them is what you would do
to protect everybody you know of a broad
feeling of messaging in a way that they
do what's necessary to protect
themselves and give them the resources
to do it
you know everybody should be wearing a
mask when they're out should be avoiding
crowds should keep distances should be
washing hands should be doing the kind
of of almost obvious things that you
need to do if we did that whether you're
an essential person a grocery worsen a
frontline worker the chances are that
you are not going to get infected what
we can do for people like the healthcare
workers we've got to make sure that they
have the proper personal protective
equipment we should never be in a
situation where people are putting
themselves in harm's way to take care of
others and yet they're putting
themselves at an unreasonable risks so
that's one definitive thing we can do
make sure we have the resources and the
equipment to protect people who are
doing essential jobs for us great thank
you
well Tony I think this hour has been
unbelievably informative and I would say
inspiring since first the time I first
met you got more years ago than I care
to remember
you've really been an inspiration to all
of us about what public service health
and science me and I am confident that
our students really benefited from your
message today so thank you for all you
have done and all you will be doing to
help our country and thanks again for
your time we really appreciate it
well thank you John thank you for having
me it's always a very enlightening and
enjoyable experience dealing with you
and with the students to Georgetown so
thanks for having me take care of John
thank you
you